okay so we've been watching convicted
Trump personal attorney Michael Cohen's
testimony today might still be going on
now might be over by the time you watch
the show or listen to today's show and a
frequent question that I've been getting
on Twitter since Michael Cohen started
testifying was there's all this general
talk about Oh
Trump's involved in criminality Michael
Cohen's exposing Trump's involvement in
criminality what's the actual list of
crimes what crimes may have Donald Trump
actually committed let's dig into
exactly that question right now let's
start with campaign finance okay
Citizens for responsibility and ethics
in Washington looked specifically at
campaign finance crimes they identified
eight possible criminal offenses by
Donald Trump seven of which are felonies
okay
these are and we'll put them up on the
screen for our audience
causing a mi to make and or accepting or
causing his then lawyer Michael Cohen to
accept unlawful corporate contributions
related to Karen McDougal that's one of
the things that Michael Cohen has been
convicted of but two instances of
causing Michael Cohen to make and or
accepting an unlawful individual
contributions related to Stephanie
Clifford also known as stormy Daniels
that is also something Michael Cohen has
been has pled guilty to two instances of
causing Donald J Trump for president
LLC's failure to report contributions
from ami and Cohen related to mcdougal
and Clifford these are all campaign
finance violations and then you see this
other list causing Donald J Trump for
president LLC to file false reports with
the FEC
making a false statement by failing to
disclose liability to Cohen for the
Clifford payment on his 2017 financial
disclosure we've talked about that
before conspiracy to defraud the United
States okay so these are just the
possible crimes related to campaign
finance then before we move on I should
say if anyone's going to argue Trump
doesn't know anything about campaign
finance well Trump has been saying for
years including as far back as 1999 that
no one knows more about campaign finance
laws than him and he knows exactly how
to use campaign finance laws to get
politicians to do his bidding and that
that makes him smart knowing how to use
the system
hyperbolic to say no one knows more than
him but it's hard to plead ignorance the
campaign finance when you claimed
knowledge of it expert knowledge many
times before
so then we get on to other crimes above
and beyond the eight campaign finance
crime seven of which are felonies that I
just listed for you we get two
obstruction of justice obstruction of
justice could include the firing of
James Comey to interfere with the Russia
investigation
it can include directing Matthew
Whitaker to install a Trump crony to
oversee particular s dny investigations
into Donald Trump and others I mean
there's so many examples of obstruction
of justice that I can't even go through
all of them today witness tampering
witness tampering can include Donald
Trump's conversations with Michael Cohen
before different testimony and meetings
with investigators and House committees
committees that is Paul Manafort we have
reason to believe that Donald Trump
engaged in witness tampering related to
Paul Manafort and others okay so witness
tampering is the next umbrella and then
this is a really interesting one lying
to investigators and lying to the FBI
under oath here's what I mean by that
when Donald Trump was asked questions
which he responded to in writing by
Robert Muller's investigators those
responses were considered under oath
testimony in the same way that if he sat
in person with those investigators and
he lied that is lying to federal
investigators based on Michael Cohen's
testimony today about a number of
different things it is very possible we
don't know this yet but we may learn
about it it is very possible that some
of the written answers that Donald Trump
submitted directly contradict what
Michael Cohen testified to under oath
today this could be related to Trump's
knowledge of and involved
in the Trump Tower not Trump Tower
Moscow that the New York City Trump
Tower meeting with the Russian lawyer
for dirt on Hillary this could relate to
Trump's claims about his involvement and
awareness related to Trump Tower Moscow
plans if Trump submitted in writing
under oath one perspective on that and
now Michael Cohen under oath is saying
the opposite someone is lying they can't
both be true it can't both be true that
Trump had no knowledge in advance of the
meeting with Natalia vessel nets kiyah
and that Donald Trump jr. came in and
told them the meeting had been set and
Trump said okay that's good to hear
somebody's not telling the truth there
and if Trump said the former in his
written submission to Robert Moeller
were also talking about a crime for
which other people wrapped up in this
thing so far are going to be doing time
so this is just the beginning of the
list of possible crimes and there's
already a lot of them and I know I'm
missing some but we have limited time
and the the potential crimes of the
president at this point are are great so
that's as far as we're going to go with
the list today I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks i'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics
about political science about history
about science so many interesting things
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month go to blink is calm slash Pakman
that's be Li n ki st.com /pa K ma n